[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
en esta oportunidad está con nosotros el
doctor luis eduardo cavelier castró
gerente de la clínica marly de bogotá en
la capital de colombia quien ha tenido
que liderar una institución sanitaria en
pandemia un reto que ha complementado
con la escritura del libro memorias de
una pandemia en la clínica marly en la
que ofrece un contexto científico y
divulgativo sobre el virus y su
propagación pero también la visión en
primera persona de lo que es combatir
una pandemia en primera línea muchas
gracias doctor cavelier un placer
conversar con usted
muchísimas gracias a ustedes un placer
igualmente
si me permite quisiera empezar mirando
un año atrás que hubiera pensado si le
dicen en diciembre de 2019 que iba a
escribir un libro de memorias durante
una pandemia
pues por supuesto absolutamente
impensable tal como era impensable lo
que nos está sucediendo actualmente con
la pandemia desde diciembre desde que
apareció esta situación en china en
wuhan y por supuesto pensar en escribir
en ese momento un libro era irracional
diría yo
pero francamente pues poco a poco con la
aparición de noticias con el proceso que
se fue diseminando a través del mundo
rápidamente sí sí sí apareció la idea de
dejar escrita las memorias de tan
difícil momento por el que hemos vivido
doctor continuando con la cronología
cómo fueron esos esos primeros momentos
de pandemia es decir por ejemplo en
enero cuando en china se conoce que hay
un virus y que pronto podría llegar a
colombia como reacción a usted y cómo
reaccionó la clínica
pues mira realmente como médico yo soy
médico urólogo como gerente de la
clínica de marly aquí en bogotá hay en
mi en chía pues está en una situación
absolutamente desconocida
muy tempranamente yo yo yo yo creo que
de manera especial y curiosa muy
tempranamente nuestro jefe de
infectología del doctor carlos pérez
me avisó que había una situación pues
que le llamaba la atención sin duda
desde el punto de vista de su
especialidad que estaba apareciendo en
china esto estamos hablando de
tempranamente las primeras semanas días
de enero de este año 2020 el doctor
pérez me pidió una cita para comentarme
de esta situación ya que consideraba que
era absolutamente importante que a nivel
institucional empezáramos a prepararnos
para lo que pudiera llegar a hacer esta
situación y de lo que pudiera llegar a
ser una pandemia a final de cuentas el
doctor pérez
pues se consideró que era muy pertinente
empezar a instruir a nuestro cuerpo
médico enfermeras en fin a todo el
personal de salud de la institución así
como a la comunidad sobre esta situación
que claro rápidamente se fue diseminando
alrededor del mundo primero asia y luego
empezamos a tener noticias por supuesto
en europa fue ver frame fue increíble
porque nosotros en la clínica a finales
hacia el 28 más o menos 27 de enero
hicimos la primera conferencia
institucional sobre los coronavirus
sobre la pandemia sobre lo que estaba
sucediendo en el mundo y de manera
anecdótica también hicimos una
presentación en youtube creo que esto
fue el 31 de enero donde mencionaba yo
que hubo apenas 31 personas en la
audiencia virtual lo que pues reflejaba
el poquísimo interés que había sobre
esta esta situación
esta calma es previa al inicio de la
pandemia pero una vez el virus llega a
colombia qué pasó cómo se prepararon
ante uno de los retos más difíciles de
las últimas décadas para colombia pero
también para el mundo
si es bien interesante ante la ante la
pues la solicitud de nuestro jefe de
infectología doctor pérez nosotros en el
mes de febrero empezamos a prepararnos
muy rigurosamente de manera estricta a
nivel de nuestras dos instituciones de
salud empezamos a diseñar protocolos y
definimos por supuesto toda una suerte
de comités que de alguna manera se
encargaban de divulgar toda la
información que de manera muy vertical
salía desde la gerencia y desde las
direcciones científicas de la gente las
instituciones con el ánimo de que todos
los médicos y todo el recurso humano en
salud pues tuviera claridad de nuestros
protocolos nuestros propios protocolos
por supuesto basados en la información
que teníamos a nivel internacional que
pues era obviamente muy poca difícil de
entender era una situación inexplicable
para todo el cuerpo médico a nivel
mundial de tal suerte que nos preparamos
para
hasta que finalmente llegó por vía aérea
digámoslo así el virus a colombia
precisamente a bogotá y esto fue el 6 de
marzo que fue donde se empezaron a
disparar todas las medidas y las alarmas
que implicaba que el virus ya estaba en
colombia
si me permite viajamos de nuevo en el
tiempo a ese inicio de pandemia que le
dirías huyó de ese momento como le
prepararía desde la experiencia para
combatir el caos 19
pues yo creo que la experiencia es yo me
diría que hay que poner muchísimo más
atención a estas situaciones que se
empiezan a divulgar a nivel mundial de
las gentes mundiales por ejemplo la
organización mundial de la salud de la
volpe en fin hay que ponerle muchísimo
más atención
[Música]
en la salud digámoslo así a los sectores
de la salud tienen que prepararse muy
rápidamente y por supuesto debe debe
haber una serie de directrices
gubernamentales muy claras muy hacia el
mismo norte para que todo un país toda
una comunidad pues pueda asumir las y
acoger las propuestas
han sido unos meses difíciles y seguro
que con largas noches y poco sueño que
es lo que más le ha preocupado en este
tiempo doctor
pues mira
el sueño lo ha quitado muchos temas
relacionados por supuesto con la
pandemia ha habido momentos muy
difíciles muy complejos sin duda
momentos difíciles
resaltaría rápidamente hoy 23 momentos
el primero es la gente la gente a nivel
de la institución manejar
el estrés las angustias las
preocupaciones esas situaciones que cada
persona nosotros tenemos alrededor de
2.000 personas por las que debemos
cuidar por supuesto al interior de la
clínica de las clínicas
hombre manejar esta situación es muy
difícil porque cada uno tiene sus
propias angustias sus propios afanes y
miedos
entonces manejar en general las personas
fue difícil pero precisamente en el
libro hay un capítulo donde mostramos
toda la cantidad de actividades que
realizamos para el bienestar de nuestro
personal que fueron momentos su programa
mente valiosos lindos además
y eso lo repetimos constantemente
durante la durante la pandemia ahora
hemos repetido y le seguiremos haciendo
por supuesto mientras que esto acaba el
otro tema dificilísimo sin duda es el
lado de los pacientes que sin duda la
familia sufre mucho ese tema del
aislamiento de las familiares de los
pacientes es duro muy difícil no estar
con ellos muchos pues en realidad no se
pueden visitar cuando falla es una
persona es es algo que duele y que
nosotros mismos no es triste eso eso es
difícil de manejar y sobre todo cuando
tenemos situaciones en que la clínica
está hoy llena de pacientes y tomar por
cesc por ejemplo hemos tenido solamente
gracias adiós digo yo dos casos en que
nos ha tocado tomar la decisión
si el paciente debería ser llevado al
intensivo o no decidí deberíamos
situarlo o no las desgracias las
familias fueron pues suficientemente
conscientes de la situación y dada la
situación compleja pues en conjunto y
con los comités de ética respectivos
pues se tomó las decisiones que yo creo
que gracias a dios gracias a dios se
tomaron correctamente guiados siempre
pues por la ética profesional
usted es doctor y estos meses hemos
visto imágenes muy duras con el personal
de salud en contacto con el virus a
pesar de vivir una pandemia usted sigue
recomendando la medicina como una
profesión apasionante y que se debe
profesar
uy sí sin duda alguna alguna yo creo que
hoy en día todavía más realmente los que
estamos en esto los que vivimos en esto
sin duda yo tengo mis actividades
gerenciales pero yo no yo nunca ha
dejado de hacer medicina como urólogo
que soy y hoy cara y le les recomiendo
de corazón a las personas que
que tienen el deseo de ser médicos no es
que ser médico no es solamente pues
hacer unos estudios difíciles largos
complejos sino sentir al ser humano
sentir el dolor de las personas ser
comprensivos ser cariñosos el ser un
verdadero médico lleva mucho más que
simplemente tener un título otorgado por
una buena o prestigiosa universidad es
bastante más de tal manera que hoy en
día pues aparte lo duro lo difícil lo
angustiante que esto ha sido porque
créame lo que es todo esto es
inimaginable lo que uno siente la gente
del común fuera de las instituciones y
mire francamente yo creo que no tiene
capacidad de entender lo que nosotros
vivimos y sufrimos al final de cuentas y
esto estamos hablando de todas las
estructuras de salud en el colombia en
latinoamérica y en el mundo
y es una profesión lindísima a final de
cuentas es dura hay momentos tristes
pero hay muchísimos momentos felices y
eso llena llena el alma
doctor chevalier muchas muchas gracias
por su tiempo
dios quiera bendiciones para todos por
favor cuídense mucho porque esto
pareciera que todavía queda un buen
trecho por recorrer muchas gracias
ya nuestra audiencia puede encontrar más
contenidos como este en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]